apporter une réponse à la menace russe
c'est ce que préconise un rapport
parlementaire britannique d'une
cinquantaine de pages dévoilé par les
députés de la commission parlementaire
du renseignement et de la sécurité
le document n'apporte toutefois aucune
preuve tangible pas de mise en évidence
d'une ingérence russe donc mais les
députés membres de cette commission
appelle le gouvernement britannique a
mené sa propre enquête sur la question
les indications fournies par le
gouvernement ont montré qu'il n'y avait
pas eu d'ingérence réussi dans le
processus démocratique britannique ni
d'activités ayant eu des répercussions
sur les élections notamment sur les
résultats cependant le scandale
s'explique par le fait que personne
n'avait fait de recherches à ce sujet il
n'y a pas une enquête afin qu'il puisse
faire une telle déclaration mais aucune
tentative n'ayant été faite pour
examiner les faits à cette déclaration
était donc plutôt creuse la diplomatie
russe a immédiatement réagi et balayé
d'un revers de main ces insinuations
rien de sensationnel de la russophobie
plein de fausses nouvelles
un rapport qui intervient quelques jours
après que londres a accusé les
renseignements russes de cyber attaques
visant des laboratoires qui recherchent
un vaccin contre le coronavirus une
accusation également démentie par le
kremlin
le royaume uni n'a là non plus avancé
aucune preuve pour le moment